>>Presenter: Welcome everyone and thanks for
coming.
We’re very pleased to have Doctor Galina
Mindlin here today.
Doctor Mindlin is an assistant clinical professor
of psychology at Columbia University and a
supervising attending physician in the St.
Luke’s Roosevelt Psychiatry department.
She also has a PhD in neurophysiology and
neuropsychology and studied at the Moscow
Medical Academy with the developer of brain
music therapy clinical treatment.
She’s the founder and exclusive provider
of this treatment in the U.S. and she recently
co authored the book, Your Playlist Can Change
Your Life which describes this therapy and
other ways music can enhance your life.
She’ll discuss this book here today and
be sure to pick up a copy of it in the back.
Please welcome Doctor Galina Mindlin.
[Applause]
>>Galina Mindlin: Good afternoon.
Let’s see how it’s working.
I’m working right?
Yeah, so that’s cool.
Thank you guys so much for having me.
How are you doing today?
[Audience murmurs]
Good?
Cool.
So let’s see.
Oh cool, so this is, okay so Your Playlist
Can Change Your Life, this is an attempt how
we can view something we already love and
we use every day; music.
Through the lines and frontier of neuroscience
which helped us to understand how we can use
playlists more effectively.
Everybody knows how it feels to put the right
music when you wake up, right?
This is very cool that if you have your playlist
ready so you can retune yourself to the day
but if you don’t you just like hear those
annoying sounds.
So in the book we’re going through several
places, like we’re advising you what would
be the best wake up playlist.
Of course everybody has different styles and
preferences.
But what we are playing for you in this book
is a variety of different playlists and why
do we do this?
The playlists can relieve your anxiety, really
enhance your focus, can make you happy, can
actually get you into better shape, create
your calm and put you in the optimum mindset.
So what is music?
Even we think music is a mystery by Darwin
but it still has very organized oscillation,
of rhythms, harmony, resonance.
This is something we should apply to the brainwaves.
Music is a stimuli, you can really think about
the music as if it’s a logical stimuli which
can trigger the different states in your mindset.
And, again, this is what I mentioned that,
interestingly enough, that music and brainwaves,
they have a lot in common.
And sometimes described in technical terms,
as I mentioned amplitude, resonance, applied
to the brainwaves and the music.
Music expresses differently by different datas
but really can influence and enhance your
ability and language and other skills.
Music can send a signal to our brain for us
like when we were born and genetic competence
was really important, really plays a big role
for us in many stages of our lives.
And the calmness, which is interesting, requires
the most power, much more power than your
activated mind.
So the calmness require more energy for you
to stay active.
Music like a scent and usually bypass many
pathways in your brainwaves.
Not all but just after the smell is the second
one and that’s not rare talent.
You can practice your musical ability and
you can even expand some the areas in your
brain.
And, again, your brainwaves can be translated
into the music so everyone in this room has
its own music so your brain plays music and
I can tell you little bit later how you can
do it.
So music, we perceive the music as condition
stimuli; it can influence many states and
this is just without taking medication so
you can do the same with the certain frequencies
of music as you do with the medications, stimulants
but you just don’t need to use the stimulants
or some rare type of brain stimulator.
So we talk about, in the book, in details
how you can bring the change in your life
and put yourself in the optimal set, mindset.
How you can make your mind flow cause it’s
very important that you make your mind flow
through the day.
How you can create calmness in different states
and basically how you can bring your brain
in an automatic creation of calmness when
you need it; if you talk to your boss or,
for example, you have a conflict with somebody.
You can increase your alertness and intensify
the release of feel good hormones without
taking substances.
And I can stimulate into the best organizational
mode.
This is probably lot of us would need this
through the day.
Remembering, memory, you can use the music
of certain frequencies to improve your memory.
And what is interesting that you can use the
music to enhance your creative ability to
build the bridges and to build in you your
own pathways.
And, again, you can tap into your own soundtracks,
if you wish, because every brain plays different
music which belongs to you and your brain
as a signature.
So this is probably one the last times we
were stress free, would you agree?
When we were in our mom’s womb and just,
you know kind of floating around.
And this is the first sound, the first music,
which is engraved in our brain; those vibrations
of the placenta.
And the first beat.
[Snapping]
It’s a heartbeat.
So everything starts with frequencies.
This is why the musical frequencies is very
important.
They deeply ingrain while the brain is developing
the frequencies are changing and with the
first spark of life you really inhale in those
frequencies.
So while, then, you know, we’re going through
the different stage of development and even
when, you know, when you ask people, for example,
when I do the EG recording and ask people
what is the most relaxing state, just how
you can put yourself in relax mind, like what
you can envision; 90 percent of people would
say ocean waves.
So, let’s see.
[Ocean waves]
Those are the sound, the wonderful sound of
Niagara Falls waterfall.
Let’s talk about a concrete example, for
example, let’s call her "Jane," this is
one of my patients, so she’s about to enter
her boss office and she’s extremely stressed
out and she’s always stressed out and she
comes to her boss office but she instantly
goes to her iPod and she hears waterfall.
And she really discovered that when she traveled
to Niagara Falls to see her Grandma several
years ago.
She wasn’t actually able to understand why
it’s so hard for her here.
So her Grandma, even she came to the U.S.
when she was two years old, her Grandma was
sitting, hours listening to this sound of
waterfalls, the same as her mom did when she
was pregnant with her.
So now she can really use the sound, the cues
of waterfalls, those frequencies, as her prescription
for staying calm.
Cause there’s this, I wanna actually share
with you the sound of my calm.
It’s a beautiful sound of white snow in
Russia; I was born in North Pole where my
father is polar aviator pilot.
And every time I’d go to Kindergarten, you
know, every time the sled would put with deer,
so dogs, I would go to, just to this like,
kind of like white bright snow and this is
the sound this white bright snow it’s deeply
engrained in me so I every time I want to
just pursue some task, I have to take all
the sounds off even for the minute and it
works for me very well.
Actually this is not my pair but I had a pair
in fox, station in fox.
Then this is like I wanted to do some exercise
with you guys, that’s interesting, the exercise
I wanted to do with you also was a movie,
which was supposed to work.
And this is something you guys try to imagine,
okay, try to use your imagination, close your
eyes.
I know it’s hard cause we don’t have a
sound.
[Laughs]
And we don’t have an image in it.
But we have so much brain power in our head
so we can easily put ourself in this relaxed
state.
And really try to envision the ocean waves
and try to envision those nice frequencies.
They actually would match your alpha wave
which is from 8 to 12 hertz.
This is why we’re so drawn to the ocean.
Most of the oceans meets those frequencies
and just stay there.
Imagine the blue sky and the breeze around
you; beautiful.
You open your eyes.
Thank you guys, you know, working with me
on that cause you know there’s no image.
So those the brainwaves, right?
I mean the brainwaves you probably know and
I’ll just, you know, really quickly.
Beta state is you state, like there different
beta waves but the subset beta in beat you’ll
really appreciate, those the beta from the
like 12 to 15 up to 18 hertz.
This is when your brain really is maximal
effective, like an optimal state.
The alpha state you just demonstrate yourself,
everybody can do this.
It’s from 8 to 12 hertz when you sitting
with your closed eyes and try to relax and
try to take all your worries away.
When you wanna drive little bit deeper to
the theta state which is 4 to 7 hertz, you’re
going to the dream state.
To sometimes the people that have problem
with attention, adult or children, they very
often stay in the state for awhile.
See though they’re very [inaudible] the
kid with ADD, pick up your garbage, call your
friend, do your homework and the child is
looking at this like, “Huh?”
So that is a theta deep state which is very
hard to come out of.
This is like listening to the kids or someone
is blasting the techno music or electronic
music like, “What is he doing?”
What he’s actually doing, it’s very therapeutic,
really trying to get himself or herself from
the theta state and bring to the marks of
beta state as best they can.
So when you see kids or yourself, when you
stuck in the theta state it’s very actually
important to bring yourself into higher frequence
mode.
And delta, this is something trance state,
you can reach out by doing the meditation.
Some of the people are very good in that.
But that would be very much physical with
training.
Music changes brain wiring.
Remember like when we get older we’re losing
some neuro connections and that’s something
you can restore with music, with certain frequencies.
Actually, you can expand your neuro circuit
which is, it’s like learning to surf, if
you arc your playlist you will be able to
keep that memory flow, that neuro circuitry,
much longer.
How does it work?
I mean, it may seem like very simple.
We know we found something we like, right,
like our favorite song sounds very good.
And then about the music, the great thing
about music it effect all areas of the brain.
I will just show you the areas of Brodmann
and you see that music really kind of tap
in to affect all areas.
It may help you through the day.
In the book really guiding you through how
to create the task oriented playlist, it’s
very important; driving to work, talking to
your boss, unwinding after the job, going
to the date, going to gym.
And then again, I mean, technically speaking
music really affect the way you think, the
way you feel, the way you behave.
So those areas of the Brodmann, right, so
if you see I was trying to put for you the
how we can respond, how our brain respond
in terms of the music tape.
The music comprehension, area Brodmann 22
and 42, they’re responsible for harmony,
melody and rhythm and those little bit of
details.
But the main thing that you can actually hear
the sound.
[Coughing]
You can see the sound with area 19 and musicians
have little bit bigger area of 19 and they
recover from stroke much easier than non-musicians
because the area is bigger.
But the good news for you guys you don’t
have to be musician, you have to practice,
not necessarily playing but listening.
Listening is a great practice as well.
So, for example, just before we were setting
up the sound I think one gentleman came and
said, “Can you make temperature little bit
higher?”
So because it’s hard to take information
in when there’s something uncomfortable,
the same for the brain, you have to adjust
those frequencies.
So the brain is in a maximum state for you,
everybody’s different, when it’s balanced
between the relaxed and activated.
What we call the best mindset.
It’s like cup of coffee, unless like you’re
like not in a French bistro and you have to
make cup of coffee, you put coffee in microwave,
it just get a little bit hot, you pour the
milk, it get a little bit colder and you put
the sugar, so basically you’re trying to
make the adjustments.
The same for the brain, you have to make the
adjustments to make it work.
You have to power the sound with imagery,
it’s very important cause I was showing
you data of the brain, the temporal area is
emotionally and especially bright and brilliant,
very sensitive to the imagery.
So if you can power the sound with imagery
just try to think of something nice like when
you’re on vacation, when you had a good
time, not a time when you had a conflict with
somebody.
Just kind of when you went away for several
days and your mind were completely relaxed
and try to use those frequencies as something
you might use to listen to your vacation,
something nice frequencies.
Try to power up with this and really will
replay a time for you when you get anxious.
Emotional memory is very powerful.
You know, some of you probably remember when
they were on top of the game.
So that I think you will do much better if
you practice this playlist and the competition,
you know like many of us have the very significant
moments in our life.
When we power that visual image, we saw a
memory; wedding song, birth of a child, your
favorite date, falling in love, winning the
competition; tons of those moments powering
specific sound frequencies.
So this is the example of how music can really
triumph over tragedy.
This is Russian figure skater Ekaterina Gordeeva
who was skating with her husband who basically
they were winning all the competitions before
Sergei died on the ice.
He died just after they won two gold medals,
making history while training for the competition
that on ice.
He just dropped dead on the ice from heart
condition.
Ekaterina in two years she came onto the ice
and she was dancing.
Like two years she was rehearsing the certain
movements, under the certain frequencies of
the Mahler 5 symphony.
And that, actually, would make you stronger
and your objective, your objective actually
feedback from that fullness, was that she
felt double strong because she really felt
that Sergei was with her and she was embraced
and those music frequencies they were dancing
together actually helped her to survive the
tragedy.
And for some us who watched their performance
really felt like healing power in the heart.
So dealing with stress.
[Laughs]
I mean you know, sometimes lose the file or
something happened like sounds is not working
[Laughs]
This is how the people would react.
And she probably would not be excited to hear
anything at that moment but if she would listen
to her playlist before, if she would try probably
she would react little less tense.
And this is also the one way, like how many
people resort to something destructive?
And in our minds sometimes there are destructive
paths because there is a hopelessness and,
as you know, like you gain three quarters
more brain power to go to some creative way
but also you can really help yourself to use
the training of the certain stimuli not to
get to that stage.
This is on the one side of the town.
In the other side of the town there’s this
lady, I don’t wanna say patient, the young
lady who has a passion for [inaudible] and
fire dancing and she was diagnosed with terminal
form of Leukemia while she was preparing for
competition.
And she got the green light from her doctor,
from her oncologist to stay in competition
and it was supposed to be for in 6 months.
All she doing, almost 24/7, she was dancing
and she was embracing herself with those frequencies
that she loved, something she was listening
from her childhood.
And if it’s something you loved hearing
actually turned in the competition and put
in the power imagery when she was little she
would love to go to the ocean and watch the
eagle coming through the sky free.
This is how she was imagining herself, like
moving very slowly under those frequencies
and she really embracing herself and connecting
herself with this eagle who flying free.
When you watch this woman you would never
think that any disease or any terminal illness
can steal that power she has in her through
her movement and those frequencies she has
engrained.
So she’s becoming an eagle.
Let’s look at the concrete things because
that’s something that help you in creating
your playlist and this is something we are
sharing with you in the book extensively,
this is just a snapshot, low frequencies something
like very familiar.
And, again, everybody has different styles,
different preferences and this is something
that you guys will prescribe or it will be
prescribed of your playlist.
We just advising you the ropes, you know how
to get there.
So very low frequency, New York, New York,
right, 40 up to 50 beats per minute.
If you’re going to something everybody knows,
Strawberry Field that would be about 90 beats
per minute.
Then we go higher like something we could
do, I don’t know, like some disco pop songs
like Adele, “Set Fire,” 125.
High alert you probably go like high techno.
There was a Pandora station playing like when
I came there was about, I think, 140, something
like 140, 150.
And then you can actually match your playlist
with a specific task.
We also advising you how you can actually
get yourself in better shape if you would
put the certain playlist while you exercising.
It’s very important what exactly, what frequencies
you put while you’re exercising.
When you’re jogging, when you’re light
walking, when you do the cardio, the weight
lifting, that is something you can also create
yourself cause I don’t know your preferences;
you love what you love.
But the frequencies is very important for
you to get into the shape and just remind
yourself that mind and body is very connected.
So assembling your playlist; you first pick
out the song you like, that’s easy.
And then you pay attention when the song works
and when it doesn’t.
It also depends on your mood, depends how
you feel through the day.
Do you guys hear the sound?
[Music plays]
It’s kind of going to space.
Okay, then you ingrain some in your memory,
it’s very important.
It should be filed, right?
You know how to file the certain things you
do, like in projects on the computer there’s
a file keeping it in your brain, don’t forget
to file it.
After you file it, make it task oriented,
it should be task oriented to drive into work,
again, some important meeting, you have a
speech, you have the deadline.
You show many playlists as you wish.
We’re telling this in the book how effectively
to do this.
You have to train.
You have to train your brain the same way
as you train the muscle because sometimes
we forget we have to train our circuitry,
right, we’re going to gym, we’re trying
to build a beautiful shape but the mind is
the same; you have to train it and you can
use something fun to do this.
Look for new songs, old songs, you have to
arc your playlist.
Guided imagery, BPM is important.
Emotional connection is very important.
So, again, how you can influence the amount
of exciting neurotransmitters in your brain,
how you can do this guys?
How do you do that?
How someone can enhance their faucet of neurotransmitter
performance, many ways, right?
Many ways, many pleasurable activities but
some pleasurable activities are very exciting
for us.
We waiting for them, we’re anticipating
them it’s even going higher when anticipating
the pleasurable activities but some of the
pleasurable activities are not that great
for the brain.
Maybe they feel good but they’re not that
cool in the long run.
Like substances, in a big amount, or things
like that.
So you can really use the same frequencies
because what you’re doing for the brain
waves and basic time and you put them like
in a very high beta like, almost gamma state,
like when you using lots of substances, let’s
say.
Or when your dopamine is like really going
up to the roof so you have to get it balanced.
But in order to get yourself there you can
certainly use the certain frequencies.
And we actually tell you in the book how to
do this.
You can certainly use that song which brings
you to this happy moment in a healthy way.
And then you can train it.
You remember that happy moment when you have
when you use that song and you would do this
every time you wanna dive into this moment
and stay there as much as you want.
Memory, that I think is also, cause you would
appreciate, working in Google, how music can
enhance your memory.
This is a very interesting story about Paul
McCartney’s first album.
He actually wanted to record in some exotic
place; he went to Lagos, Nigeria and that
was actually the beginning of a very cool
journey but it took a couple of unfortunate
turns; his band left besides his wife Linda
and Blue Moon guitarist, John Wayne.
And what happened was he was stripped of his
valuables at the gun point and he had to give
his musical score, he didn’t have it anymore,
so he had to rewrite, some of you guys probably
know that story, he had to rewrite everything
from the memory.
And, still, at the album of 75 who got the
Grammy award by Rolling Stones magazine is
announced one of the best.
So it’s really possible to write such a
complex musical score by memory.
I think I have another one.
This is German composer, Mendelssohn, he wasn’t
robbed but he managed to leave his music score
in the taxi when he was riding in the taxi,
so he had to rewrite all of the music composition,
all the harmony and frequencies he wrote before
from memory and he did.
Just exactly as it was original.
So there was research, evidence based research.
One of the Mozart sonata, I would love to
play it for you guys and I’ll try it.
[Music plays]
Mozart Sonata actually was shown, D major
K448, improve your memory, increase your IQ.
And we’re showing you in the book how you
can enhance your playlist with the Mozart
Sonata, how you can do this.
Because it really open up the pre-frontal
area and then there's a certain graphic area
in the brain can increase your cognitive ability.
Healing effect of music, it’s very hard
to underestimate that the god of music and
medicine is the same in Greece.
And over the centuries, everywhere you go,
right, you go to different ceremonies you
go to weddings, funerals, music is everywhere.
Armies use certain frequencies of activation
that’s how the brain of the soldier stay
aroused and this is how they can go without
sleep 24 hours.
By marching those frequencies, which they
really ingrain and practice in their brain,
this is how they go on.
I gave the presentation recently to NASA pilots,
like after we finished the study in Washington,
on those responders.
So those something for those guys to use while
they switching the time zones, it’s very
important.
But this is more involved than music you can
really create from your own brain.
And music is really sort of a human obsession.
Music therapy, some of you probably know that
it’s very effective form of therapy and
it’s proven, actually, how it helps with
stress, helping to improve communication skills,
reduction of distraction symptoms, reduction
of destructive behaviors.
There’s huge studies right now in Cochrane
Review like 2,000 people using just relaxing
music for the patients with cancer, for the
pain, post op, post procedures, post operation.
Now we’ll be talking about your music, the
music which comes from your brain which we
call brain music treatment.
So brain music treatment, brain music waves
which are created from your own brain wave
frequencies and, again, everyone has different
frequencies.
As we say genetic competent is important and
the signature of the brain is very important.
So I would love to play for you, there is
two files; activating and relaxing.
Activating and relaxing, activating files
created mostly from your fast waves as we
will have, you know, high beta and beta.
And relaxing is created from your own slow
waves which is alpha theta
[Piano music]
Okay, it’s activating, I can’t play it
very long because I get very activated.
It’s my activating file; what was I thinking?
[Music plays]
Great, and this is my relaxing.
Sorry guys I cannot do this that long cause
I would fall asleep.
I’m just kidding.
[Laughter]
But actually what we showed and across the
board, and I’ll show you the studies, it’s
effective in 85 percent of the people suffering
from insomnia and about the same effectiveness
for people suffering from anxiety or social
anxiety.
So
how does it work, right?
>>audience member: So where exactly did the
songs come from?
You said it’s your song, so it’s your
brainwaves?
>>Galina Mindlin: Yes, yes.
So I’ll just tell you in a moment.
The brainwaves are recorded on EEG and then
they are converted to the musical sound and
they are placed on two files for you that
you can put them on Mp3 or CD.
And they actually based on what you need for
the day.
You can use activating file when you tired
through the day, when you feel like very relaxed,
you want a little bit perk up and relaxing
file you use when you feel like very high
strung, very anxious and you use at night
when your brain just can’t shut down.
Like for some of us we go to bed and what
do we do?
Just lay there and think, think with our brain
like a shadowbox this is how you can unwind
your brain by using your own relaxing file.
It’s a pretty complex algorithm and I don’t
want to bore you guys but basically it’s
a translation through harmonic free analysis
of alteration of the brainwaves we have.
With this algorithm we translate allegoration,
for those that play a little bit of piano,
like 36 notes, 3 piano octaves and 8 volume
gradation and duration segments.
In the first study we did we used about 120
algorithms just to show that this treatment
is effective.
So this is what happened.
This is the first graph of someone who suffers
insomnia.
So you see there is a stage, you guys know
a little bit stage 1, 2, 3, 4, this is a deep
sleep so this person with insomnia doesn’t
have a deep sleep, they just go and they hear
enough sounds, enough to bring music treatment,
the treatment really would allow you to dive
to the delta sleep and the amount of sleep
cycles would increase after the brain music
treatment; from 2 to 6 or maybe none to 4
and 6 so this is impressive.
You see that your total sleep time was increased.
SOL, that’s sleep onset latency, this is
the amount that you just lay in bed and, you
know, counting the sheeps or elephants, really
decreased from an hour to 9 minutes, right?
So you’re not awake during the night and
your delta sleep increased.
It’s very interesting we also did the comparison
with Ambien, and you know that Ambien sometimes
could be actually quite harmful for you, right,
decreasing your short term memory.
So those is the study we did in Canada.
As I mentioned to you the anxiety goes down
when using your authentic brain music, an
insomnia skill and the sleep is better when
using your own authentic brain waves music
compared to I would use some of yours.
This is what were the double blinded studies
we used.
We have a group that use their own authentic
brain waves and who use somebody else.
So this is the study, just finished the study,
so this is the base line with the sleep quality
and trait anxiety and you see even on the
week 3, on the third week when people are
listening to their own brain music, right,
their anxiety goes down and they actually,
they sleep, the amount of time laying in bed
counting the sheep is significantly decreased
so your insomnia improved.
On the week 6 your insomnia continue to improve
and the anxiety goes down.
Those are some complex slides and those something
we did in Washington with operational chief
command, first responders and the control
group.
Those pretty complex graphs for those of you
who interested I can tell you more, with insomnia,
again, and with a peak performance.
Yes, we can.
Actually that is something we can use to practice
and repeating certain sounds.
It’s something a lot of politician would
use, right, to engrave some message into your
right temporal area and the frontal area,
the repetition.
Yes we can.
You guys really can find out a lot of things
and your playlist can change your life.
You can change the way you respond to life
challenges, which is true, just by the push
of the button you can do it.
And you can walk a path of charged happiness
and wellness, it’s true because you really
can bring a positive change and enhance your
life.
Many people did and you can do this.
May the concepts and techniques we described
within our book, Your Playlist Can Change
Your Life, serve you well as they have for
me and each of my other co authors.
Yes, we can.
[Laughs]
Thank you guys.
Questions please.
[Applause]
Do you guys have any questions I may answer
for you?
Yes?
>>male #1:How much are you samples of just,
standard population, how much actual musicians
or separate cultures that have like more melodic
based languages, like how much of that was
taken into consideration?
>>Galina Mindlin: You know, the gathering
data in terms of the playlist there were a
lot of us and no musicians, just college students.
You know, we’ll have the medical students,
the people who run the corporation in terms
of the playlist.
In terms of the brain music, all the groups
we had, I mean there were people who were
suffering from insomnia and people suffering
from anxiety.
So there were two target group and in terms
of operational chain of command and so those
were our first responders, firefighters, so
those are the people who have to be their
optimal best.
So there were no musicians, I think there
was one musician, actually, in Canada.
Yes?
>>male #2: The civil music you were playing
have almost as much effect as the individualized
one is that because the [inaudible] just someone
else’s brainwave music?
>>Galina Mindlin: You know what happened with
the placebo which is somebody else brain music,
right, could be effective at some way, you
know?
Not as effective as your own but the effect
would fade away like on about 7 to 10 days
it would fade away.
This is the first study we did we did with
medical school about 25 years ago, something
like that, so this is when we took the group
of medical students and just gave them their
own authentic and somebody else and it was
effective, somewhat, not that effective from
the parameters [unintelligible] then the effect
would fade away like next week.
Some more questions for you guys?
Yes?
>>male #3: Have you ever tried recreating
the custom sound after you use it for a couple
weeks and see if there were any changes?
>>Galina Mindlin: After you use your own?
Yeah, we recommend actually that you would
come to retune your first sample.
The same that I would adjust the medications
and we don’t study the follow up, that’s
what you’re saying, I mean, like follow
some sonography after you use it.
But we list the changes on baseline, you know,
EEG and in this study like I said, we did
post sonography but not like in a huge sample.
Of course, I mean, there were like a soft
picture of, for example, your fast brain waves
they come in common so this is what we showed.
This is how you can dive into delta sleep.
But how you can make it more proficient, that
is something we are about to study.
Like, for example, in a year.
For example, in Italy we have some people
that would use their CD for years and you
call them and they’re like, “I don’t
want to come in cause I like my CD.”
[Laughs]
Nicely put, why would they come?
But we actually recommend that you would come
to make it just more perfect.
In the book, I’m giving you a lot of examples,
you know, how to use your playlist, how to
combine it in a different variation, how to
create task oriented playlists.
Yes?
>>male #4: If I listen to my favorite song
too much will it lose its effect?
>>Galina Mindlin: Yeah.
Yeah.
>>male #4: [inaudible] wondering if you knew
if for EMT is there a limit to how much you
listen [inaudible]
>>Galina Mindlin: Yeah, that is a great question
actually because, I mean, certainly when you
use, when you do something pleasurable too
much, I mean, too much is too much.
So you really go to desensitization to your
brain waves, I mean, you can decrease this
effect.
What we actually noticed with activating file
you really have a limit.
You cannot listen to your activating file
more than two times.
Some people do three.
I mean it just like with people who have very
heavy ADD but we do not recommend more than
two times because we actually noticed that
people get too activated and this is something
that you don’t want to do.
And just with your playlist sample you really
have to arc your playlist, you know, it’s
like you have to do some novelty.
You have like given a new style range, something
you love like rock and roll, techno, rap,
doesn’t matter but you have to upgrade it
within your style.
Within your preferences.
Just stop with the desensitization.
Yes?
>>female #4: What’s your take on Pandora
and the shuffle feature to create your playlist.
Does that have any value at all to like the
spontaneity [inaudible]
>>Galina Mindlin: I think there is definitely
value in a certain way if you’re asking
me about like neurophysiologic response I
think there is some, you know, anticipation
kind of desire, your transmitters don’t
know what is next.
I think it’s cool but what do you do with
this therapeutically.
I mean if you like something like be a young
age or something I think it’s cool just
for fun.
Guys, more questions?
More songs?
Yes?
>>male #5: In the movie [inaudible]
>>Galina Mindlin: Yes.
>>male #5: [inaudible] have something horrible
happen
>>Galina Mindlin: Yes
>>male #5: [inaudible]
>>Galina Mindlin: Let me incorporate right,
yeah I remember that movie, wow there were
some horrible things there like when there
was that music.
Are you saying like when something happened
when he’s sort of appearing, something horrible
happened right?
And the music is pleasant.
I mean we have different personalities, styles.
I do supervise the unit with personality disorders;
I mean there is this variation, so there’s
personality traits.
And the best, I mean, again, we’re talking
about the creativity the best when you appear
to something positive to something positive
cause if you have something, negative like
event in your life, you can’t reverse it
with a positive but not when you’re in kind
of perpetrator mode or
[Laughs]
>>That is what I mean; you can through the
tragedy, that you can do the training.
Some more questions, guys?
[Ocean waves]
You guys can do it, actually, every day for
yourself.
Just for five minutes.
It’s very restorative for your brain to
use the natural sounds to bring yourself from
that state you were coming from, it’s very
restorative.
I would recommend.
I do it.
So, something else, guys, you would like to
hear some sounds we may miss?
Something you want me to play for you from
what I have?
On the tape we were playing?
[Laughs]
So do you guys want little bit activating
file just to stay active?
But it’s mine, I don’t know if you want
to do this.
I know it’s little bit too activating.
Let’s do maybe some of the Mozart for you
so you guys will feel, you know, active.
You guys are not forgetting the book, right,
cause I mean; I don’t want to tell you everything.
[Laughs]